good morning Hank it's question Tuesday
the day that I answer real questions
from real nerdfighters no time for the
intro we have to get to the questions
have you ever forgotten to be awesome
and totally humiliated yourself
best wishes among all three of your
books which one do you like the best I
don't know I can't pick Hank pick for me
Paper Towns did you have any fishing
boat proceeds this year man that is a
reference that only like the hardest
core nerdfighters are going to get and
know it's another year where I failed to
profit from the oceans bounty what would
happen if you blend Erised awesome mmm
awesome smoothie what advice can you
give to young writers read what's your
favorite songs from a hat song left on
the right side of the road what do you
think with the best movie of last year
Juno what's your favorite quote you
shall love your crooked neighbor with
your crooked heart are you in the Yeti
planning on having kids soon mom why are
you leaving me questions for question
Tuesday I'm trying to be professional
here
what is the opposite of jokes tragedies
like hey you remember when you stole my
ex-girlfriend that was really tragedies
Darth Vader or Lord Voldemort Vader and
I'll tell you why he's completely free
of unicorn blood favorite mountain goat
song up the wolves apples or oranges you
just can't compare them if you could
watch only one movie for the rest of
your life what movie would it be
Rushmore would you rather drink your own
pee or vote for one of the current
Republican candidates
well that completely depends on how much
pee is involved because like a few drops
sure I move about an hour away from you
and I was wondering if I could just like
come by your house someday would that be
totally weird yes that would be totally
weird how's it going pretty well I'm
just answering some questions Tuesday
why are you distracting me I have to
answer so many questions in your opinion
what is the least useful superpower I
don't know like supersonic knitting the
ability to tell time with your moustache
who's your favorite vlogger on YouTube
Hank
if all the nerdfighters in the universe
collaborated together to write a book
what would it be about the evil baby
orphanage and that would so be a dream
come true for me
what was your favorite childhood toy I
think the question you mean to ask is
when Hank was a child did he like My
Little Ponies and the answer a
resounding yes what do you look like
without glasses like this wait where's
the camera would you ever sing in a
karaoke bar on a double dog dare no it's
a well-known fact that I don't believe
in the binding nature of the double dog
dare what color is your favorite shirt
blue contour Nietzsche Conte yes or no
yes
movie cookie dough or cake batter cookie
dough the Rolling Stones are the Beatles
Beatles can we have Daniel Biss make a
cameo on a video absolutely any book
recommendations sweet scarlet by Maureen
Johnson and three little words by Ashley
Rhodes quarter what's your favorite word
in the English language - whisper I was
gonna say love but then I thought of a
better one what country would you most
not want to visit decepticon Nia has all
your leg hair grown back yet it's still
a little sparse around the shin can you
name a one word oxymoron lightweight how
do you recommend I keep up with question
Tuesday when you talk so damn fast I
don't feel like I speak particularly
quickly is there gonna be a character
named Hollis in Paper Towns no but
that's a very funny question to hardcore
fans of my books why doesn't the Yeti
want to be seen it's not her it's me I
worry that her cute would break the
camera what's your favorite mathematical
constant I because I like to use my
imagination nerd jokes nerd jokes nerd
jokes why does no one at school talk to
me even though I'm an intelligent okay
looking and funny seventeen-year-old you
don't know how much I wish I had an
answer for that question but the good
news is this there are lots of people
who will talk to you at the Ning Alaska
or Lindsay Marta Roth Spiegelman what's
your least favorite law of nature the
one that requires me to always be taking
actions in order to get any reactions
who the eff is Hank Hank is a sausage
covered in cornbread batter and
deep-fried can we make our own
nerdfighter shirts yeah lots of people
do I mean just look at all of that
awesome when a nerdfighter goes
underwater does the nerdfighter get wet
or does the water get awesome the water
gets awesome would you ever want to take
a trip to Nepal can I use one of your
radio pieces as a monologue if you could
make one world problem go away forever
what would it be and do you like cheese
yes yes poverty and yes how many pushups
can you do at one time I can only do one
at a time why are you so devilishly
handsome because YouTube is so
devilishly blurry what's your favorite
Shakespearean insult now lumpish shrimp
alien bum bailey what's your favorite
dewey decimal number three oh six point
eight seven five where all the books
about conjoined twins hang out are you
guys ever gonna throw a nerd fighting
convention I don't know maybe what do
you guys think is this the last question
you'll answer
whoo yes